all right let's get a little more
practice taking limits of composite
functions so here we want to figure out
what is the limit
as x approaches negative 1 of g
of h of x and the function g we see it
defined graphically here on the left and
the function h we see it defined
graphically here on the right
pause this video and have a go at this
all right now your first temptation
might be to say all right well what is
the limit as x approaches negative 1
of h of x and if that limit exists then
input that into
g so if you take the limit as x
approaches negative one
of h of x you see that you have a
different limit as you approach from the
right
than when you approach from the left so
your temptation might be
to give up at this point but what we'll
do in this video
is to realize that this composite limit
actually exists
even though the limit as x approaches
negative 1 of h of x
does not exist so how do we figure this
out what we can do is take right-handed
and left-handed limits
let's first figure out what is the limit
as x approaches negative 1 from the
right-hand side of
g of g of
h of x h of x
well think about that what is the limit
of h as
x approaches negative 1 from the
right-hand side so as we approach
negative 1 from the right hand side it
looks like
h is approaching negative 2. so another
way to think about it is
this is going to be equal to the limit
as h of x approaches
negative two and what direction is it
approaching negative two from
well it's approaching negative two from
values larger than negative two
h of x is decreasing down to negative
two
as x approaches negative 1 from the
right so it's approaching from
values larger than negative 2 of
g of h of x g of
h of x i'm color coding it to be able to
keep track of things
and so this is analogous to saying what
is the limit
as if you think about it as x approaches
negative 2 from the positive direction
of g
here h is just the input into g
so the input into g is approaching
negative two
from above from the right i should say
from values larger than negative two and
we could see that g
is approaching three so this right over
here
is going to be equal to 3. now let's
take
the limit as x approaches so now let's
take the limit
as x approaches negative 1 from
the left of g
of h of x
so we could do is first think about well
what is h approaching
as x approaches negative 1 from the left
so as x approaches negative 1 from the
left
it looks like h is approaching negative
three
so we could say this is the limit as
h of x is approaching negative three
and it is approaching negative three
from values greater than negative three
it's going h of x is approaching
negative 3 from above
or we could say from values greater than
negative 3
and then of g
of h of x so another way to think about
it what is the limit
as the input to g approaches negative
three
from the right so as we approach
negative three from the right g
is right here at three and so
this is going to be equal to three
again and so notice the right hand
limit and the left hand limit in this
case are both
equal to three and so on the right hand
and the left-hand limit is equal to the
same thing
we know that the limit is equal to that
thing
and this is a pretty cool example
because the limit of
you could say i guess the internal
function right over here of h of x
did not exist but the limit of the
composited function
still exists